[Applause]
thank you hi I'm going to talk about
future importances today and
specifically about the loaf of
importance that I developed with some of
my colleagues at ING that is open source
as well and on github so let's start out
with an example so some of you may have
participated in this cattle competition
it's Microsoft malware prediction so
Microsoft puts a malware data set and
asked us to predict whether a machine
will soon be hit with malware or not and
one of the features that are in the data
set is the operating system version so
that centers OS version and well if you
think about it that should be a
indicated feature predictive feature
because some versions are more prone to
bugs than others so we and we probably
know this right if we train our model on
some versions that we'll learn which
versions are more buddy and which are
not but what if you have data that is
okay you train the data and the model
learns on the training data but then you
have a test data set that is like a
future data set and your model hasn't
seen this time in the future so there
will be new versions in that data set
and then the model will not be able to
know whether these versions are buggy or
not right so what happens is if you use
three model importances they typically
look at the training phase they look at
the tree structure that is constructed
during training and they calculate
teacher importances from there so they
would give a very high importance to the
e version so for instance here I got
this from from a kernel on on Caudill
and you can see that the OS version is
the sixth most important version marked
by light GBM with the importance of gain
so what else is out there so the future
important set that are out there are the
first three here are specific for trees
tree models so there's the Gini impurity
there's the game they're the split and
those have this problem that I just
mentioned they don't generalize well
if you have seasonal features they're
not they might be given falsely high
importance also these three importance
is tend to overestimate the importance
of very granular features there's also
the Shapley values or the sava score
which is actually quite similar to what
we do and I'll describe that in a bit
but it's only implemented at the moment
for three models so it's so all four of
those are very model dependent and
there's also the permutation matrix
which does look at the test at but it
overestimates the importance of
correlated features and too low for
importance so leave one feature out what
we do is actually we want to we want a
model that will generalize to unseen
test set and we want feature importances
to reflect that so the nofo algorithm
first looks at all the features it
calculates the performance metric based
with all the features in and then it
iterates over each over all the features
and then one by one it removes them from
the model retrains and evaluates across
validated performance so what this does
is well it solves the previous problem
that I mentioned and it's not biased
towards the training set and also what
we implemented is that it's you can put
any so I could learn friendly model for
any performance metric any validation
scheme and also when you have a feature
that could actually harm you if you use
it in the training it will give you a
negative importance for it so if we go
back to the example we have a kernel
here on cago which would show you this
is it visible all right so here we just
import the data we define the target and
the futures and the way to call our
class is just low for importance you
give it the data the future is the
target the cross-validation scheme so
here we chose k-fold for instance and
the scoring metric and if you don't give
a model it will just default to like GBM
and what you get is for every feature
you get the
the mean of the importance across the
folds and the standard deviation and so
going back to the example of the
Microsoft malware prediction here is the
visualization we have for the future
importances so the the colored bar is
the value of the mean so the mean is
around here and then the standard
deviation is the black wire around it
and if you scroll all the way down
you'll see that the OS version is
actually the most harmful future so you
shouldn't treat e8 include it in your
model yeah so that's it install it try
it out it's on github just some caveats
it is slow although we paralyze because
you iterate over all the features and
it's bound to happen it's so far still
misleading at like the permutation
importance when it comes to correlated
features but we're working on that and
we're going to implement a leave n
features out component which would then
flag all the correlated features and
give them the same importance if let's
say they're very very highly correlated
thank you and also we're hiring data
engineers and software engineers
[Applause]